make the start here this afternoon his
second start of the season and we
mentioned his start against tampa bay
last year he was 14 and five with a 232
in run average here's has drupal cabrera
[Applause]
ground ball beshette to his left and the
flip to vizio covering to retire the
side eric petty 28th big league start
yeah last star the 25th against the
yankees got the no decision after four
innings of four hit ball gave up two
runs one earned three strikeouts one
walk
beau swings and fouls it back and that
clocked jill west on the side of the
head on the follow through
joe west has a bleeding ear
and it'll look like beau's bat
hit joe on the side of the head and his
ear is bleeding on the left side so joe
west walks off with paul lessard that is
vic carapazza who comes in from second
base to now become the home plate umpire
they'll get a chance for guriel right
here and look at the infield in the
first inning the infield is going to
play in popped it up shallow left field
could be trouble
it'll drop
and bechet is going to scamper home with
the first run of the ball game but now a
walk in a base hit and two in scoring
position with two down for michael a
taylor the left fielder
and he got him same pitch same result
and a couple of men left on as ryu
gets out of trouble here in the top of
the second he has stolen two for two so
far looked like a good jump the throw
short good tag and out is the call stu
sherwater on the call quite a pickup by
carter keyboard good pitch to throw on
right kind of cleared kurt suzuki from
the hitter nice pick by kibum and
hernandez just slid right into carter's
glove once he picked it covering did he
tag his hand he did it looked like joe
west is on the field and he's empowering
third base he went straight hockey
player they took him under stitched him
up and he's back out and the nationals
will have runners at the corners with
two outs faces suzuki hit well to the
gap in right center the nats will tie
the game and it looks like they'll take
the lead castro around third
2-1 washington as kurt suzuki hits two
line drives today and that one finds the
gap in right center here's taylor who's
struck down in the second inning one on
one out and taylor gets a big piece of
that one deep left center
see
you
later michael a taylor 0 for 12 career
against ryu
prior to that swing taylor with his
second home run of the year both of his
hits here in 2020 have left the yard and
the nationals lead this one four to one
roundy teles will lead off for the blue
jays up the middle
key boom to his right i throw and it's
pulled down by cabrera
carter kibum having one of the best
games of his young career today that's a
hernandez had a base hit his first time
up now he swings and sends the ball to
deep center field and it's high off the
wall and in play
big bounce back in toward the infield
hernandez is around second and on his
way to third and in there with a stand
up triple and tay oscar asks luis rivera
the same question i'm about to ask
wasn't that a home run and it looked
like that ball
bounced back from the other side of the
wall
and it is a home run after review
clearly hit up on the railing above the
green wall as a homer so tejaska
hernandez says his third home run of the
season and the blue jays are back within
two top of the order beset he drops one
in the dirt suzuki blocks it trusting
his veteran catcher who won hop cabrera
with that throw lead off double gotta
make this one count dribble cabrera
gonna try to at least get him to third
here with nobody out the other way
that's gonna back up bidgeo maybe get
over his head it'll one hop out there
and coming around the score is castro
move the runner indeed from second to
home
and the gnats get that run right back
the blue jays just scored cabinet vizio
the batteries oh for three
it's not going to get to 3-2 as a fly
ball to right field deep and gone
kevin biggio with his second home run of
the season and it's a two-run game
second home run of the year for bizio
and that ball hit it on the nose high
and i think maybe the wind might have
helped because of the way the outfielder
goes after it
loaded and one out here at the top of
the eighth leading this game five to
three
well that'll get part of the job done as
big gio has to back up two runners will
advance
home is key boom row blaze to third and
the nats have the answer for a toronto
run again
getting their three-run lead back
oscar had a home run off fetty in the
fourth inning it's on top of that one
and drills it to deep left and he's got
another one and look at where that one
landed
what a monster shot for tea oscar
hernandez
and takes on danny jansen
out to right center roble's tracking it
checking his surroundings at the wall
yes
victor robles grabbing it right off of
the wall out there
what a play by victor robles
yeah that's the tip of the cap for sure
i mean went a long ways kind of size it
up watch him peek at the wall as he's
going full speed here just to see where
he's at right there a little peek
and then jumps as high as he can right
on the o and geico a big first out
here in the bottom of the ninth up by
two runs victor robles do it
biggio a towering homer into the natch
bullpen last time
swing and a miss and the nats win it